speaking of smooth it was josh allen all
night long it was smooth and and in in a
rhythm here and you know we you you were
saying off camera when we were watching
the game chris just how josh allen took
so much criticism at the start of the
season like is he going to be able to
leave this team he's got this huge new
contract but he has proven every single
week at what point do we believe in josh
allen yeah i wish people would
just get off his back a little bit or
stop being a hater i don't know really
what the right phrase is but hopefully
tonight on the national stage with with
patrick mahomes on the you know opposite
sideline people will start to realize
that this guy is special i mean he's if
not the best player in football he's in
the conversation i'll just say that
right off the bat they the way they play
is all because of him and his skill set
they put a lot of pressure on on your
defense because yes he's got maybe the
biggest right arm in the game other than
patrick mahomes and then we've talked
about his ability to run with the
quarterback design runs and then plays
like this where he just dances around
the pocket for a little bit and those
throws i mean that's that is like truly
special god-given talent that he has
right there and there's only been a few
quarterbacks really in the history of
football that can do some of this stuff
so happy for him because i know he's a
great leader he works hard he's improved
his game in a lot of ways
and then the bills really i think gave
him the confidence and just said listen
we're going to play and we're going to
win as you go and he's really kind of
taking the team by the reins and they
kick some butt a lot of that confidence
comes with the way the defense plays as
well right when they're on the field
they can help him out as well we'll get
to the defense in a second but you look
at this buffalo team as a whole are they
the best team in the afc east i i mean
i'm going to say yeah the definitely the
best team in the afc east and i'm going
to say the best team in the afc i mean i
i am i mean again i know you know we've
got a lot of other good teams out there
with the chargers and i'm certainly not
counting out the kansas city chiefs uh
who else is the baltimore ravens but i
think with the way buffalo's defense is
playing the game plans week to week too
it's not like oh no this is what we do
and we just we're not going to change
much week to week leslie frazier and
sean mcdermott do a lot of creative
things you don't know what you're going
to get they're patient enough with the
run game and then with josh allen
running the brian dabal offense it just
has all the answers let alone if it
doesn't have an answer guess who does
josh allen makes a play and he makes
some amazing throw or scramble to kind
of help them out that way so uh yeah i'm
going to say buffalo's the best team in
the afc and in some ways i think they're
the best team in the whole nfl
altogether wow yeah i'm gonna say that
all right let's talk about a play that
will be discussed there'll be water
cooler chat tomorrow and that was the
roughing the passer call on that josh
allen received
what did you make of that well again you
know it was 31-20 right early fourth
quarter
kansas he had all the momentum and here
we're going to show it here he throws an
interception on a deep post here and a
third down there's nothing there you
know again i know what i think they're
trying to call body weight right there's
a body weight call this really one of
the fouls that you know reggie white
used to kill my dad with this is one of
those things but again josh allen has
jumped in the air left the ground it's i
don't know i just think it's over
officiating a little bit again the game
is not perfect he has two feet off the
ground and yes the guy is about to hit
him right around the midsection so that
leads to him falling on top of josh
allen it's just one of those i wish it
wasn't called we're getting a little too
carried away in my opinion with illegal
touching the quarterback it's like okay
come on it's still football and being
able to intimidate the quarterback
position is part of the sport and i
thought that totally changed the flow of
the game or at least took kansas city's
chances of winning the game out
completely
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports